i discharged mr. Walker  you've come far my friend now just  remember when in doubt trust my brain  not my eyes please release him to his  parole officer too bad you weren't  released a week earlier you could be  standing with your father right now your  constant companion for the next 13 days  of house arrest it'll ring twice a day  pick it up before it rings 10 times you  screw up you go straight back to the  Institute  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I'm not sure highs  [Music]  a little brother no this isn't real  you're in prison is that so Alex what  are you doing here I heard about your  dad passing away I just want to say I'm  sorry  maybe through these next 30 days Oh  barely out the gate what do you want  what are you looking for me chances  aren't the two of you there no long  person party  this is real sometimes it takes two men  to make brother how about your price not  your fight  [Music]  27-month years to come  you  [Music]  you